Let’s talk about US sanctions on Iran
because the US president
keeps piling them on.
Powerful sanctions will
go into full effect.
but Iran isn’t bowing.
Now, according to this online tracker
America has more
sanctions against Iran
than it does on North Korea, Cuba
Venezuela and Libya combined.
So what exactly are
those sanctions
and more importantly,
are they working?
The big picture is this:
the US and Iran are,
in a way, at war.
States like these and
their terrorist allies
constitute an axis of evil.
But they don’t fight
face to face
Instead, they antagonise
each other.
Iran gets involved in conflicts
around the Middle East
by backing armed groups
and US rivals like Russia.
And the US's main weapon?
Sanctions.
Now the simple definition
of a sanction is:
“an official order, taken
against a country
in order to make it obey
international law.”
That could include bans on travel, transactions or trade.
And in Iran’s case,
it’s all of those.
Any kind of exchange
that directly or indirectly
might benefit the Iranian
government or any agency of it
or any individual who may
directly or indirectly be
affiliated with it is prohibited
under American law.
Now we’ve read the US Treasury’s blacklist for Iran
and it is long.
The big ones are: a ban on Iran’s biggest industry
which is oil
and a ban on any kind of financial transactions with Iran.
Plus its entire steel, mining,
coal sectors
dozens of individual people and ministries in Iran’s government
banks, insurance,
construction companies
ships and aircraft.
There’s even a ban
on Persian carpets
one of Iran’s
biggest exports
and its pistachio industry.
Now, the penalties for violating those sanctions are serious.
The US government can fine a person or company up to $1 million
or hand down a 20 year
jail sentence.
Even if they’re not American.
Because the US has
such a strong dollar
and so many transactions are conducted in dollars
it means that US sanctions
would affect any EU company doing business with Iran.
Between having sanctions on
its main industries
and being blocked from trading
with other countries
Iran has become one of the most isolated economies in the world.
So when did this sanctions
war start?
More than 40 years ago.
The US long supported Iran’s
monarch the Shah
but in 1979, the Islamic
Revolution swept
cleric Ayatollah Khomeini
to power.
A group of Iranian revolutionaries stormed the US embassy
and imprisoned its staff
for over a year.
That led to the very first round
of sanctions on Iran
with the US freezing billions of dollars in Iranian government assets.
and it was just the beginning.
Over the next several decades,
Iran came under more
international sanctions over
human rights abuses.
Iran was also sanctioned for
sending billions of dollars
to armed groups in the Middle East
like Hezbollah in Lebanon, or
Hamas in Palestine.
But it was Iran’s decision to
develop nuclear power
that really got the US worried
because Iran now had the tools
to build a nuclear bomb.
Since 2003, a nuclear crisis has been brewing between Iran
the United States and
its European allies
when it was revealed that
Iran has two nuclear
facilities that it did
not declare to the IAEA.
So in 2011, the US together
with the UN issued
a massive heap of economic
sanctions on Iran
to (a) stop any money flowing to
its nuclear programme
and (b) to pressure Iran into potentially striking a diplomatic deal.
And that part worked.
In 2015, after long and tough negotiations, a deal known as
the Joint Comprehensive Plan of Action was signed.
“A historic deal.”
“The landmark nuclear agreement
will mean that Iran
has to sharply curtail its
nuclear programme.”
“The Iranian foreign minister receives a hero’s welcome back in Tehran.
International sanctions against Iran
will now be lifted.”
We've achieved this historic
progress through diplomacy
without resorting to another war
in the Middle East.
But the truth is that many
US lawmakers
Republicans in particular
didn’t trust Iran would keep
its end of the deal.
Neither did one of America’s
closest allies.
Iran's rulers promised to
destroy my country.
Murder my people.
Perhaps you can now
understand why Israel
is not joining you in
celebrating this deal.
So as soon as Donald Trump became president, he backed out.
I am announcing today that
the United States
will withdraw from the Iran
nuclear deal.
All the old sanctions came back.
And more than 700 new ones
were issued against
Iranian individuals and companies.
It’s what the Trump administration
calls its “maximum
pressure campaign."
So when people ask:
has the US sanctions programme
worked on Iran?
Well, that’s debatable.
These new sanctions have nearly killed the entire Iran nuclear deal.
And in response, the
Iranians have said:
Well, what’s the point of us
holding up our end?
So they’ve now restarted some low-level nuclear activity.
And they will probably continue to do so until the EU takes action
to deliver on some of their commitments
which they are not able to deliver because of US pressure.
The eventual outcome could be
an Iran withdrawal
from the nuclear accord and also the death of the whole deal.
Sanctions have managed to
cripple Iran’s economy.
But Iranians are getting
around them.
“Human mules have
carried smuggled
goods across the
border for years.
Electronics, phones,
beauty products
medicines, cigarettes,
the list goes on.”
Long years of sanctions have led the Iranians to develop many
of their own domestic products inside that have substituted
for those things that they
can’t bring in.
When sanctions come,
there’s a dip.
And then, somehow, the
economy starts reacting
and responding
and compensating
and within three or four years,
it’s back to growth.
Another question is whether
Iran’s government
can survive many more
years of instability.
Don’t get me wrong, it still has
a lot of support.
But recent protests across
Iranian cities have
exposed some discontent with
those in power.
“Anger, frustration and growing concern in Tehran.”
The protests erupted after
Iran’s government
which has been strapped
for cash
increased the price of fuel
to raise funds.
In November, thousands of
people were arrested
rights groups say more
than 300 were killed
and at one point, there was a
total internet shutdown.
Iran’s leaders say they were
responding to a bigger threat.
The bottom line is: it’s not clear whether the US’s huge web of sanctions
is going to lead to any kind of breakthrough with Iran.
And there’s a whole debate about whether those pressure tactics
have ever forced any big changes in places like Cuba or North Korea
where sanctions have been
around for decades.
Those who defend sanctions say the alternative is an actual war.
But neither the US nor Iran, nor anybody else seem to want that.